DAN HERMES: Hey, everyone.
So for those who don't know,
my name is Dan Hermes.
I'm part of Developer Relations
here at Google.
I support the Content API for
Shopping as well as the Search
API for Shopping, and I'm a
member of a larger team that
supports all the Commerce
APIs here at Google.
Today, May 16, we're here
to talk about the
Content API for Shopping.
We don't have any sort of
agenda, but based on the faces
and names I see, I'm
sure we'll have
plenty to chat about.
Like I said before, if there is
an issue of with reverb of
my voice, let me know and
I can deal with that.
So before I open up the floor
for questions, I have some
questions for you guys, namely
one question that could lead
to some discussion.
And I was sharing with my team
this week, and thinking of
ways we can slice this
biweekly event up.
And I was just wondering if were
any particular types of
people that you guys would like
to see in this Hangout,
like the engineers that work on
the API, if they could come
in and be guest stars
once in a while.
Or maybe if there's Sales, or
maybe if there's people from
Ops, like we had four weeks
ago at the Hangout before
last. So any suggestions
from the floor?
MALE SPEAKER: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
here.
DAN HERMES: How you doing?
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
What about the team that
does the exceptions?
DAN HERMES: OK.
I know what you're saying.
So you mean exceptions--
something we discussed at a
previous Hangout, for those
who didn't see it, exceptions
or acceptances for accounts
and things like that, yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
That's correct.
DAN HERMES: OK.
Yeah, that's something
I can look into.
I don't have that strong a
relationship with those folks,
but I can definitely
check it out.
It certainly would be helpful to
have some preset questions
before we have a guest like
that show up, but
I'll look into it.
Anything else?
CAROLINE: Danny, is that
the same as the
data quality folks?
DAN HERMES: The data quality
folks, it's a pretty
distributed team.
There are engineering folks.
There's the support
part of that.
I'd be happy to get
either one.
I actually quite like the
engineering folks who work on
that there.
It's a big team in Zurich, and
also the API team for this API
in particular is
also in Zurich.
But that's something
we'd look into.
I know you were wanting more
parity between what you get
from the data quality feed and
what you see in the merchant
center, and that's something
our direct engineers would
have an impact on.
Is there something else you
were thinking of when
requesting those folks?
CAROLINE: Yeah, actually, it
just seems to me, the one
meeting I attended, there was
probably two or three
different times where you said
I'm not the data quality, so I
can't really answer that
question with authority.
So it just seems like a lot of
those questions come up, and I
think they would benefit
me even if I
don't have the question.
That data quality is definitely
one of the more
complicated and concerning
pieces of that.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, that's
a great point.
Maybe we could just have
like an out of band.
Rather than a biweekly hanging
out, we could have a dedicated
Q&A mixed with a bit of
lecturing on data quality.
But that's a great suggestion.
ANDREW: I--
DAN HERMES: Andrew, you look
like you're about to talk?
ANDREW: Yeah.
Can you guys hear me?
DAN HERMES: Yeah.
ANDREW: OK.
I'm not sure about a specific
guest request, but I would be
interested in hearing about new
features, what you guys
are working on.
I mean, I don't know how much
you guys like to talk about
that sort of stuff,
but if you have
project managers or something.
Even if it's just for things
like the Merchant Center, or
new graphs, or feedback,
or whatever.
DAN HERMES: Yeah,
we do have a PM.
I will sync up with those folks
and see how much they're
willing to reveal.
The thing about doing something
like that is, unless
it's pretty close to production,
it's sort of
you're making false promises
sometimes.
Because sometimes, something
will be halfway along and get
de-prioritized.
And even though it'll only take
a couple weeks of work,
there's nobody working on it for
those couple of weeks, and
things like that.
But I'll certainly look into
it and ask the PM what he
thinks about coming to this.
There are two different PMs
involved with Content API,
both of whom are pretty
interesting dudes.
So I will add them to the list
of requested guests.
Anything else?
ANDREW: Another thing that I
don't know how many other
people in this Hangout have
experience with this.
But another thing that we do
is we use our content feeds
for AdWords and other--
like Google Affiliate Network
and places like that.
It might be kind of cool to have
one of those guys in at
some point to talk about what
they're doing with the feeds,
what they like, what kind of
metadata they care about.
Because I know it's sort of
different than what is used in
the Google Shopping
Experience.
DAN HERMES: Right, right.
There is a wealth of other
attributes that you can send,
as Andrew knows.
And Andrew has probably sent
just about every possible
attribute you could send that
teams at Google are parsing in
one way or another.
And I can certainly look into
getting those people on, or if
not getting them on, possibly
getting some sort of interview
that I could play for everyone
with them about those things.
Because like Andrew said,
there are a lot of extra
things you can do with targeting
and enable some of
that within your feeds.
That's great.
So now, let's open the floor
back up like we usually do.
There were no specific
questions, again, this time,
but two weeks ago, we didn't
have any specific questions
and still went 45 minutes.
So I think we'll be all right.
So I'd say the first questions
we should jump on are the
OAuth 2.0 questions that have
been bouncing around with Luke
and Caroline.
So if you guys want to ask those
or give a recap, and
then we can jump in.
LUKE: Well, the old client login
is going to depreciate
in three years, right?
So this is not--
DAN HERMES: Yes, it's
deprecating in three years.
Client login, AuthSub, and
OAuth 1.0 are three of, I
believe, the only four methods
Google supports for
authentication, but
I don't know.
There might be more
than the four.
But it was announced about a
month ago that those three
methods will be deprecated
over a three-year period.
So you're right.
It's not that urgent.
But given the fact that it will
be going away, especially
for you, Luke, as you're
building a user base and
you're not really at critical
mass yet, the more users you
have on something, the harder
it is to switch, right?
LUKE: I'm server-to-server,
so I have to use the JWT
server-to-server
pattern, right?
DAN HERMES: Not necessarily.
If you're just using your MCA,
you can get a refresh and an
access token one time, and you
can do that server-side.
There's a special redirect URI
that isn't actually a website.
It's like OOB colon.
It's a colon-delimited
string of six things.
And you can do that one time,
get your refresh token and
your access token just for your
account, your MCA that's
making all the requests, and
you can go server-to-server
all you want.
I'm not entirely sure what the
server-to-server stuff that
Caroline was hoping to
get out of that.
But for you, if you don't
actually need refresh and
access tokens from every user,
if you're just creating
sub-accounts with your MCA for
each of your users, you only
need one refresh token.
And as long as you on your
account never revoke that
refresh token, you can use it
ad infinitum to get a new
access token every time another
access token expires.
And then from there,
if you find a way--
I was just reading about this.
There's no preset way to
serialize the data with the
DotNet Client Library,
but there is
with every other library.
But there are public
attributes.
There are public getters
and setters for
everything you want.
So before you kill your process,
if you save those
tokens somewhere safe and
secure, then you could start a
process back up, reinstantiate
an OAuth 2.0 parameters class,
at least in the DotNet case, and
then just use the setters
to set that refresh token.
Then everything else happens
under the covers when code
snippet but that's been bouncing
around the forums for
DotNet, and with every client
library, that is, if you set
up your request factory or your
service or your client
object, whatever the local term
is for it, or whatever is
doing the work of making and
sending the request, if you
set it up with an OAuth 2.0
token, it handles everything
else under the covers.
As long as you have a refresh
token, you don't have
to worry about it.
Because what the client will
do, it'll try to make a
request. If it succeeds,
it succeeds.
If it fails, then it'll get
a 401 back, which means
unauthorized.
It knows it's unauthorized,
so then it tries to make a
refresh request to get
a new access token
using the refresh token.
And then, it'll send a third
request, that being to retry
the original request,
to the API.
And then if that gets
rejected, than it
will send an error.
But like I said, all that
happens under the covers.
You don't need to
worry about it.
All you need, especially in the
case of an MCA, Luke, is
one refresh token, and
everything else
just kind of happens.
LUKE: OK.
I didn't know that you had
an interfaceless--
I could make like a post with
an interfaceless system that
would then respond
with the token.
I didn't know that.
DAN HERMES: Yeah,
you can do that.
It's server-side OAuth 2.0 is
what they call it, and it's a
server-side flow.
It's not quite server-to-server,
but you can
do a server-side OAuth 2.0.
And what you'll do there is
you'll just get a code back.
So there's a redirect that we
offer when you use that
redirect URI, a Google
host redirect.
And on that page, they just have
a text box with the code
that you need, and that code
is what you exchange.
That code only lasts 10 minutes,
whereas an access
token lasts an hour.
That code is a very short-lived
code that you can
use to exchange for a refresh
token and an access token.
But if you just search for
server-side OAuth 2.0 flow,
it's in that document that I
just posted to the thread.
But if you want to ping the
forum if you're having
trouble, I can certainly
point you in a
more specific direction.
LUKE: I have a question
about--
DAN HERMES: Caroline, does
that seem like it's--
sorry, Luke.
Did you have a problem?
LUKE: I just wanted
to ask a question
about that last point.
When you bring in these guests,
will we be told two
weeks in advance who's
going to show up?
DAN HERMES: When I announce the
Hangout, I'll announce--
it may not be two weeks in
advance, but it'll be 10 days
in advance, 8 days in advance,
something like that.
So Caroline, is that sounding
more like what you were
looking for?
Or were you really needing this
server-to-server flow?
CAROLINE: I think so.
I'm just trying to find where
you're looking in the
documentation, because what
I had certainly didn't--
the redirect URI was a page
where a user would acknowledge
and consent to that.
And we have 200-plus
merchants.
To have that kind of set up
every time we need to add
somebody to this--
DAN HERMES: So it depends
on your setup.
Luke's setup, he's using a
multi-client account, and he
creates a sub-account for
each of his users.
And then he can just administer
those accounts
using his own logged-in
credentials, because his MCA
is a parent for all those
sub-accounts.
If you have individual accounts
for each of your
merchants, one, I would
recommend going to an MCA.
But two, you're going to have
to get their authentication
somehow to make requests
on their behalf.
And asking them for their
passwords is not good, right?
So you're right.
CAROLINE: It's less
than ideal.
But the way it's been in the
past, it's not inconsistent
with what we've had to do
in the past, right?
Because this is a relatively
new model, too.
So we've been doing this
for 10 years with
Froogle and all that.
DAN HERMES: Wow, that's
remarkable.
Yes, I don't believe OAuth has
been around that long.
CAROLINE: And OAuth 1.0 was--
as my boss said, just use OAuth
1.0, and hack it, and be
done with it.
Because OAuth 1.0 apparently had
a number of issues, right?
DAN HERMES: It was
just the flow was
a little less intuitive.
There were more parts to it.
And I think one of the big
issues with OAuth 1.0 is that
you had infinite life
access tokens.
And it's the same thing
with client login.
Well, actually, no.
That's not true anymore
with client login.
But there's some problems with
giving access forever rather
than giving the ability
to refresh forever,
and, things like that.
CAROLINE: So the way the
documentation is written
certainly suggests we are a
server-to-server candidate.
But that said, it does not
seem like even in the
libraries that's supported,
it's supported too well.
There's a lot of complaints
about things not working
appropriately in their
respective libraries.
DAN HERMES: That's one of
the more exotic flows.
And honestly, I don't think
it's that necessary.
I don't know how you're
currently authenticating new
users, but it would be as easy
as do you want to sign up, and
then it's just one extra
page they go through.
CAROLINE: Yeah.
They typically talk to one of
our ECI representatives who
walks them through everything.
Because we can have very
different people, different
technical backgrounds.
One of my concerns with doing
a multi-client account is
we're a software as a service,
so we don't have a website.
We don't have a merchant
account as a company.
It's all our merchants have
merchant's accounts.
So the master one is always the
master and all the children.
And it wasn't clear how to
obtain a master account that
wasn't tied to a website that
had e-commerce platform.
So we don't want to take one
random merchant, make them the
master, and then--
DAN HERMES: No.
It would be your own
sub-account.
But the fact that you
don't have a website
may be an issue there.
CAROLINE: We have a website, but
not an e-commerce website.
DAN HERMES: Right,
right, right.
I don't know.
I think with marketplaces, you
would need an e-commerce site,
but there are other types of
multi-client accounts that
don't necessarily need
to be a marketplace.
CAROLINE: So that's one reason
that we held back.
The second reason is, obviously,
the quota is per
merchant account, and it
actually would bite us worse
as a master account than--
we'd more than likely have to
get our quotas up, too,
whereas if we just used the
separate merchant accounts,
our quotas will be higher,
and we shouldn't run
into that as much.
DAN HERMES: In that case, if
your quota volume is high, and
you're meeting it, and there
are legitimate requests, if
you're not doing something where
you're being spammy, or
you're sending more requests
than you need to or something
like that, we'll bump
your quota.
There are no issues there.
And if there are issues, then
we'll help you get your number
of requests down so you're
not hitting the quota.
CAROLINE: But using separate
accounts, I would unlikely
have to bump it, right?
Well, I mean, it's fine.
It's something we would
definitely look at if there's
a way to have a master account
that is not attached to an
e-commerce website.
DAN HERMES: I don't know that
off the top of my head, but
let me write that
down, actually.
LUKE: Well, Caroline, my site
isn't an e-commerce website,
and it was approved
as an MCA account.
CAROLINE: We tried to get our
demo sites approved, and we
just kept getting shot down.
And whoever the nameless,
faceless person on the other
side of the drop was was not
giving us any help at all.
LUKE: I had the same problem
until Sir Danny stepped in.
CAROLINE: So we just went and
got our merchant account, and
said, OK, you're going to
be the beta merchant.
We'll just start with you.
I mean, we got sort
of frustrated.
We tried for probably a month
to get something done,
particularly so we could use
it as a test platform.
Because we have test e-commerce
sites that wouldn't
damage anything as well.
DAN HERMES: So as a test
platform, that's actually
against the terms. But what
we do with the API
off of the dry run--
CAROLINE: Right, the dry
run, which is what
I've been using, yeah.
DAN HERMES: Yep.
But we can certainly, off this
Hangout-- you and I,
Caroline-- link up about doing
an MCA if you're interested.
And I can certainly help with
those channels that you said
weren't that helpful,
because I agree.
There are times where the
sign-up flow and things like
that are not as intuitive or
human interactive as--
CAROLINE: You'll probably
get a kick out
of the email, Danny.
I'll send it to you.
It was pretty entertaining,
actually.
LUKE: It was a two-step
process for us.
I mean, not only did they
decline when we first tried.
They also turned off
our appy access.
So I had to go back to Danny
twice and get it finally done.
DAN HERMES: So with that said,
to conclude that whole arc, I
think OAuth 2.0 server-side
is a pretty viable flow.
But again, you're going to have
to make that decision.
The docs are a little hard to
digest, but I think after you
implement it, the docs are a lot
easier to digest after you
try it out a few times.
CAROLINE: I think you're just
looking at a different doc
than I am, because there's
certainly none that suggests
that there's a generic redirect
URI you can use, so I
just didn't find the
right document.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, so maybe I'll
reread that and find out
if it's in there.
When you actually go into the
Google API's console to
actually get your client ID and
your client secret to do
OAuth 2.0, by default it's
server-side OAuth 2.0.
And you have to actually change
the setting to set your
own redirect URI.
By default, it's actually
set to be--
CAROLINE: Oh.
See, I didn't even do that.
I just did the server-to-server,
because that
seemed like the appropriate
one from the document.
DAN HERMES: So the server-side
OAuth actually, either using
local host, which
you need to do--
your library needs
to support that.
So local host isn't really the
one you want to use, but it's
something like EEB colon--
you know what?
Let me mute myself
and type that in.
Not that it matters that much.
But I'll be right back.
CAROLINE: Yeah, it
doesn't matter.
You can just post
it later, too.
It's not that critical.
It does make me question why
we have a server-to-server
option when it doesn't appear to
be supported or encouraged.
It's like, why is that there?
ANDREW: Have any of you guys
read the OAuth 2.0 spec to see
if message signing is
still part of the--
I haven't done OAuth 2.0.
I've only done OAuth 1.0.
No?
CAROLINE: The service accounts,
that last piece I'm
talking about, definitely
includes an RSA hash signature.
ANDREW: For the header or
for the whole message?
CAROLINE: Just the payload.
The header's encoded,
64 encoded, and then
the payload is signed.
Actually, no.
The header and the payload
are signed.
So you send the header, the
payload, and then the signed
header and payload all
as one parameter.
DAN HERMES: That's the point
of the RSA, is that you can
encode the payload.
ANDREW: They could just
use the transport
layer security there.
DAN HERMES: Right.
ANDREW: But I guess they
decided to go the more
complicated for me way.
CAROLINE: But using that first
method that Danny talked
about, it's almost seamless.
There's really no encryption.
I mean, that's all handled
in the library.
ANDREW: I'll have to look and
see if there's a good library
that I can use.
Because I'm sure that the Google
Client Library for this
uses it, but we did
some custom code.
DAN HERMES: All the source
is open source.
So you if you need to pull parts
into your own custom
stuff, the source is still
out in the wild.
It's not just a bunch of
executables floating around,
or binaries.
So I did find that string.
It's urn:ietf:wg:oauth:2.0:oob.
Not that anyone should remember
that, but that's
approximately what
it looks like.
And before we get to our next
question, I just want to say I
see we have two viewers
outside the Hangout.
We have, let's see-- one,
two, three, four, five.
There's only six of us right
now, so we have four open
spots if you want to actually
join the Hangout and not just
watch from afar, and
hang out on air.
If you prefer to watch
than hang out on air,
that's fine as well.
Anyhow, on to our
next question.
Yule or anyone?
Anyone?
LUKE: I have my usual
question or two.
I did get an exception for items
that include group item
ID must not have multiple
values.
And this was because a merchant
was trying to submit
two colors.
And the way I take them is I
take them as a comma separated
list, and then I just parse
them out of the comma
separated list and list
them separately.
So how do you want that
submitted if it's like blue,
white, blue, red.
Do you want blue comma white,
or slashes, or--
DAN HERMES: Well, so if it's
like they have four of the
same shirt that are all
in four different
colors, that's one case.
Or if they have a shirt that
has four different colors,
that's another case.
So which one do you mean?
LUKE: Well, let's just a
take an example of two.
You have two shirts, and they're
each multi-colored,
but there are two colors.
Like it's a blue and
white shirt, and a
blue and red shirt.
And you can only submit
the attribute for
the color one time.
So do you want blue comma white,
blue comma red, or blue
space white, blue space red?
DAN HERMES: This is the
sort of an amalgam
of everything, right?
So if you just had a shirt that
was both blue and white,
a multi-colored shirt, and
you would submit blue
slash white, right?
Now, for this particular
product, you have a shirt that
sells blue-white and a shirt
that sells red-white.
So you could submit two
different products with the
exact same data, one blue-white,
one red-white.
And we actually have support for
this through variant IDs,
and that's actually--
LUKE: But not like
that, though.
I mean, the shirt itself has
two different colors in it.
So you're submitting one color
attribute for one product, but
you want to put two colors
in the attribute.
DAN HERMES: Right.
So what the docs say, whether
you're using the API or
whether you're using data feeds,
you need to pick a
dominant color, and then from
there, list the rest after it.
But the example we have in our
example XML in our docs says,
I think, red slash blue.
But in the single attribute, you
would do blue slash white.
So scp colon color red slash
white, blue slash white.
So color, actually, before we
made the big switch to all the
variant IDs, you used
to be able to send
more than one color.
But now you can only
send one color.
But read up on variant IDs.
We can discuss it a
little more if you
have specific questions.
LUKE: Yeah, I'm already
using variant IDs.
DAN HERMES: Oh, OK.
Perfect.
LUKE: I'm doing all that.
Just I've gotten this weird
error about how you can't
submit them as separate
color values.
DAN HERMES: Yep.
You need to submit one color,
and then, like I said, if
there are two multicolored
versions of the same shirt,
then you would need to submit
them as separate variants
under the same variant ID.
LUKE: And I have a
stupid question.
Are digital downloads considered
hard product that
we can list?
See what I mean?
Because it's like, let's
say you have a report.
It's a bound report, right?
That's something you ship.
That's a hard product.
But what if you want to offer
a digital download version.
Could that also be listed
with the appy?
Because it's a digital
product.
DAN HERMES: I don't
know why not.
I don't know the specifics
of it.
Let me write that down.
As far as I know, if it's a
product, it's a product.
But I don't know 100%, so
we'll leave it at that.
And I'll write this down.
I'm going to mute myself so
you can't hear me typing.
LUKE: I think it's a stupid
question just because I feel
like I'm too lazy
for not digging.
I'm sure it's in there
somewhere.
It's in the doc somewhere.
DAN HERMES: Sure.
Do we have any questions from
our newcomer, Hope?
No?
Are you finding this helpful?
That's good, that's good.
HOPE: Yes, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: I've got a
question to ask about
documentation.
DAN HERMES: OK.
What's up?
MALE SPEAKER: You sent out a
link on the forum this week
that the documentation's being
changed or updated?
It's also labeled "sample
documentation."
DAN HERMES: What's that?
MALE SPEAKER: It was labeled
"sample documentation?"
DAN HERMES: Yeah.
So, it's not that something
was being changed.
It's that I added an end-to-end
PHP sample that
showed you how to insert
products in batch or
individually, how to update,
like, pretty much every action
you would want to do on
your items using PHP.
And I have one in Python that
I published three weeks ago,
and hopefully, the DotNet will
be published this week.
I don't know if people saw all
the commits made to the DotNet
library, but it's just
a new guide.
It's just augmentation
rather than changes.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
Thanks for clarifying that.
DAN HERMES: You're a Java
guy, though, right?
MALE SPEAKER: I am Java,
that's right.
DAN HERMES: So you don't
care about the PHP.
MALE SPEAKER: I had a quick
glance at the PHP.
It looked good, it
looked good.
DAN HERMES: Sure.
OK.
So do we have any other
questions or concerns?
CAROLINE: Hey, Danny?
I do have a question.
I know you kind of pushed me
to go down the web server
application route.
It's still an additional step.
I mean, you have to have them
set up a merchant service
account to get either the client
secret and client ID or
to get the private key.
DAN HERMES: No.
I wasn't advocating
you do that.
Your application has a client
ID and a client secret.
And then your application
performs OAuth 2.0 as--
CAROLINE: Got you.
But then again, we would still
need to have a master service
account, right, to do that?
Or no?
DAN HERMES: No.
CAROLINE: Doesn't that
account have to be
attached to a merchant?
DAN HERMES: That doesn't
have to be tied to
your account at all.
CAROLINE: OK.
That I was unfamiliar with.
Now I got it.
DAN HERMES: So what happens
is, you need to sign the
request on behalf of
someone, right?
So OAuth 2.0 is a way to get a
token for doing the signing.
So if you get a token on behalf
of your users, it
doesn't matter what account
retrieved that token, right?
It's a token for the
user's account.
And when you sign the request
on behalf of your users,
that's what that is.
So you could use a Google
account completely independent
from the accounts you're using
to manage everything else.
But you could use that account
for OAuth when you go through
and set it up, and
you'd be fine.
So you need one client
ID and one client
secret for just you.
And then from there, you'd use
that client ID and that client
secret to actually construct
the token--
CAROLINE: The OAuth
request, yep.
DAN HERMES: Right.
And then from there--
there may even be
a video online.
I might try to track
that down.
But from there, your user is
presented with one page, two
pages if they're
not signed in.
CAROLINE: Yeah, I think it's
seeing the page where they
agree to it and all that.
DAN HERMES: And it even says--
because you specify the scope in
the request, so it'll even
say, they're only wanting to
access your Content API for
Shopping data.
So all our tokens are
scoped tokens.
So if you've got an OAuth token,
and then you try to
access, let's say,
their calendar
data, that would fail.
CAROLINE: Right, right.
Yeah, that's pretty clear
from the documentation.
So then with that question in
mind, say I am using whatever
generic Gmail account that
I have, and I do the
server-to-server.
How am I able to access
their accounts, the
very last one that--
DAN HERMES: I'm not familiar
enough with server-to-server
to tell you.
CAROLINE: Because maybe there's
enough trust in that
original account?
I don't know.
Again, it seems ideal to
not have to have their
interaction, but it's just
unclear from the documentation
what that last one is.
DAN HERMES: I don't understand
how you're going to get their
authorization without
some interaction.
CAROLINE: Well, that's
what I'm asking you.
The service-to-service account,
if the private key
generated is not associated with
their account, then how
is that an authorization?
Because my understanding
was they
created the project account.
They generate a private key
that is for their merchant
account, and then everything
signed with their
private key is golden.
DAN HERMES: I see.
OK.
Yeah.
CAROLINE: Maybe if we had a
better understanding of how
that works.
DAN HERMES: Like I said,
I'm not familiar
enough with that flow.
It is one of the more exotic
ones out there
for the utmost security.
Yeah, I mean, like Andrew said,
usually TLS is good enough.
But that goes above
and beyond.
But I can look into it
more for our next
Hangout, if you like.
CAROLINE: Yeah, or even just
post on the forum sort of how
that queue thinks, as well as if
we go that direction, their
response error is, on
purpose, useless.
It's just that didn't work.
And I think that's so that you
don't try to hack it and keep
trying to get the right
answer, right?
I think it's by design that it's
a obtuse error message,
but having maybe more
information as
to why that's happening.
I mean, it does appear
to be used.
There's enough people on forums
talking about it.
Maybe it's only used for--
DAN HERMES: Individual
accounts?
CAROLINE: Or individual APIs
that really don't contain any
kind of sensitive data, and
that's the whole point, too.
I don't know.
It's just not clear.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, I mean,
especially with this API, all
the data is intended
to be user-facing.
So we don't really care about
encrypting it that much.
User-facing via either commerce
search, or product
search, or product ad, some
other destination.
CAROLINE: And the worst thing
somebody could do is if they
got your account is to
get it shut off.
I mean, that's not good,
but it's the worst they
could really do.
DAN HERMES: Sure, sure.
CAROLINE: Sorry.
I'm done beating that particular
dead horse.
DAN HERMES: No, no, it's fine.
It's very important.
I think especially with client
login going away, it's
important to understand how
all these flows work.
But also that's sort of the new
way authentication happens
on the web with OpenID
and OAuth.
It's not just Google.
It's everybody.
And with a lot of these
libraries, client login was
super-duper easy.
You just put in the account
ID and the password,
and you just go.
Or that is, the email,
not the--
merchant center account ID.
But I think that stuff's
pretty dangerous.
There was a talk last year at
Google I/O, called Client
Login Fail, going over
all the ways where
bad things can happen.
It is kind of scary having
to send passwords around.
That's why we rely on these
millennial flows rather than
the old school.
LUKE: Danny, I wanted to ask
if anybody had seen this
happen, and maybe I just
need to double check.
But it looks like when a
product is posted, the
Merchant Center Console shows
a created date-time and an
updated date-time.
And at some point thereafter,
it switches over and says
posted, right?
And it doesn't say created
or updated.
It just changes the display?
DAN HERMES: I'm not
familiar with the
posted attribute, but--
LUKE: It might even be
after the product
is approved or something.
But anyway, the post seems to
change, and it says posted.
And then, what I think I
noticed, and I've got to
double check this, is that
when it switches over to
posted, the appy starts
returning an updated
date-time, but it doesn't
tell you when
the product was updated.
The updated date-time comes back
as the current date-time
of the request. Maybe I'm
wrong about that.
I don't know if anybody
else noticed or not.
DAN HERMES: Huh.
So I did ask about that before
you were asking about updated
and published signatures
changing.
The team says either that's a
bug on our part or you're
making some sort of changes
before doing that that you're
not registering or realizing.
LUKE: I need to double check.
Let me check my stuff and
make sure I'm right.
DAN HERMES: Yeah.
I don't know the behavior
of all this.
Nobody's really noticed it.
I'm not sure.
But unless it's critical to your
application, I'm not too
worried about what the
values are or not.
I don't know.
If it is critical, you want
to know when it ends up on
product search or something
like that.
LUKE: I think originally what
I was doing was I was
comparing your date to when it
was updated to my system's
date that was in the process
of updating and that was
determining whether I should
fire an update.
I do it internally now, so I can
keep track of when it was
last modified, and I compare
it to the current time that
I'm running to determine
whether or
not I should update.
DAN HERMES: I would recommend
doing that, and possibly even
maybe Andrew can talk about
scalability a little bit.
But possibly even saving
responses for some
predetermined amount of time so
you can go back through and
get stuff out that you wanted.
But for somebody like you where
you have an interaction
with the user, and the user is
actually changing something in
the database, it's not too
difficult to have a database
hook where you either add
something to a queue or you
immediately fire
off a request.
LUKE: Right.
You're right.
DAN HERMES: I don't know if you
wanted to make a comment,
Andrew, about what you guys do
or what you think a best
practice is, for how long you
should save responses or how
often you should
save responses,
or things like that.
ANDREW: For us, it's a little
easier because we have so many
different things that consume
this product data that we
actually already have a system
where every change has a time
stamp, and you can compare the
last time stamp that you sent
to the time stamp of when
the change happened.
But I keep separately a record
of the last successful send.
I don't query the data
back from Google.
I just assume if I got back
a "2 something something"
request or response, like a 200
or 205, then the change
committed to Google, and I don't
have to tell them about
it again for another month or
until another change happens.
LUKE: Did you notice, Andrew,
if the updated date-time
reflected the current time?
Or have you just never
looked at that?
ANDREW: I haven't used the
DotNet framework for that, and
I haven't looked at
the responses.
I don't plan on using that.
DAN HERMES: I mean, he's
just referring to--
they're in the Adam
Namespace--
published, updated.
I think he's saying
posted also.
They're all in the Adam
Namespace, and they come back
in the responses.
ANDREW: And I actually thought
that was supposed to indicate
how fresh the data was.
not when the data was changed
in Google's database.
It was a long time ago that I
looked at that particular
thing, but I thought that was
to indicate for like if you
had a client that was getting
multiple pieces of data or
interacting in some way.
So the current date-time might
actually be right in that
case, or at least at the
date-time of the request
DAN HERMES: Like some crawl to
a product page, you mean?
ANDREW: No.
I was thinking like if you do
an API request and it comes
back with a time stamp on the
response, I thought that was a
time stamp for how fresh the
data in the response was, not
when the data changed in
Google's database.
LUKE: I guess it doesn't
matter that much.
I probably should let you know,
Danny, if that's the
case, that it is giving you the
current date-time in case
your engineers had really meant
that field to mean the
last time it was updated in your
system just in case it
comes up in the future.
DAN HERMES: Let me
experiment here.
I'm going to use our demo, and
actually just make a request
and find out what happens.
I will share the screen
in a second.
Actually, no I won't.
I don't want to reveal my
account ID, unfortunately.
Sorry.
CAROLINE: I had a pen
all ready, too.
DAN HERMES: Actually,
it goes on YouTube,
so it's never gone.
ANDREW: I think it might be
relevant to mention that the
account IDs, I know everybody
in the forum spends a lot of
time trying to hide them.
They're actually not
very secret.
You could get them off of
the Google merchant--
you can get them off of
the shopping search.
And actually, they're also
somewhat sequential.
So you can kind of guess, like
the last number has some
repetition in it, but the rest
of them are pretty sequential.
But yeah, I know there's people
who are like, I don't
wanna know--
I don't want people who know
what I've been posting.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, so I am
noticing that the updated time
stamp reflects the current time,
and the published time
stamp did not change.
But I don't know what the
implications of that are.
And I don't see a posted time
stamp, but this account
doesn't really have anything
posted, so suspicion confirmed
to a degree.
So, do we have any other
questions, or are we
going to wrap up?
MALE SPEAKER: Danny, just
a quick one about OAuth.
ANDREW: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry,
Daniel, sorry.
Just a quick question
about the OAuth.
I've had a quick look at
the documentation.
It's great you've got it
in the PHP, OAuth 2.0.
I just had a glance at the Java,
and it says coming soon.
DAN HERMES: Yes.
So, I didn't write
the Java one.
And that was actually
in reference to
OAuth 1.0, I assume.
It's on my list of
things to do.
I just finished the other three
guides, because they
didn't exist. The Java one
has existed for months.
MALE SPEAKER: It's OK.
It was just a comment, really.
I wasn't chasing you
or anything.
DAN HERMES: I don't know if
you're using the client
library or which client library
you're using, but they
have instructions within
the source.
So if you're using the Google
API Java client or whatever.
I can't remember the name 100%
off the top of my head, but if
you're using that one and you go
to the wiki, there's a long
OAuth to wiki explaining exactly
what you want to do.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
DAN HERMES: Sure.
All righty.
Well, I'll see you guys
again in two weeks.
I will make an announcement
relatively soon whether or not
I'll be having somebody
as a guest star.
And I will post some of these
questions that we had, like
this published or not question
and what the relevance of the
keys are in server-to-server
things, and then also about
getting an approval for an MCA
without an e-commerce site.
CAROLINE: Yeah, I'll send you
the email I have just so you
have whatever you're
looking for.
DAN HERMES: All righty.
CAROLINE: Thanks, Danny.
DAN HERMES: Have a nice
day, everybody.
See you.